[Music]
and why people wanted news
whoa submitted by I'm the one cool
China has a booming industry for foreign
workers oh whoa never white people wanna
come over still their job I heard about
this it's been going on for the past
five years I heard that they look for
white people to work in their theme
parks to be like like British soldiers
or like mm-hmm
I can't speak right now got uppercut in
the [ __ ] job so I'm slurring my words
right
you know why people shoulders I bit my
tongue shoulders shoulders of British
shoulder what's up what the ladies
though in the I really don't know what's
happening in this photo but I just know
that these people were all hired but why
would they wanna so what's happening
right now
or what's been happening is that China
is hiring foreigners preferably white
Westerners to give more diversity
legitimacy to their business cuz they
they believe that if there's a white
foreigner facing like for the face of
the company then it's like it must be
legit it's dead up just following the
rules to legitimize their business
they're like let's get a white guy put
exactly yeah and then they even have
like hired people to do like all these
crazy different jobs so they have to
pretend to be an architect
like pretend to be oh they're not even
legit they're actors they're all actors
yeah what how come what can't you just
do anything right I know I know that
there's like the whole like
counterfeiting like type of [ __ ] that
they always give me fun of right but
kind of it a job is the book I don't
know you could even think of something
like that yeah so apparently you're
saying that in China there's this
misconception that foreigners are rich
skilled or educated oh yeah so that's
why these products that are being made
in China they want to have like Western
sounding names that we like
face of a westerner for the face of the
product or the company to give it more
legitimacy because it's seen as superior
like if there's a Western sight better
branding yeah exactly it's pretty genius
though
yeah like made in America is always
considered away better what if they
start just like telling the
manufacturers just print made in USA on
there they like but it's actually made
here okay we just take a picture of the
board meeting and in this all he's hired
why actors and [ __ ] oh my god they're
even counterfeiting the company yeah
like for example there's this one girl
her name's Katie's 25 she speaks fluent
Mandarin she moved from New Jersey to
Beijing she's saying that like the jobs
weren't covering her bills so then
that's when she came across this rent a
foreigner gig so they wanted a foreigner
for a part-time position and so the role
was the assistant to the director of the
firm but her bowl all she had to do was
just entertain clients through a dinner
so during dinner it's already like known
that you don't discuss business so she
didn't have to pretend to know anything
about the business cuz cuz it wasn't
gonna be discussed it was just the face
like do you just wanted her face to
legitimize the firm even more and so she
says that she got paid a thousand yuan
which is about $145 per dinner so that's
how she's making a living for being a
rented foreigner dude that's so [ __ ]
funny it's like instead of just being a
company with good products and integrity
hey like look that's out of the question
we got to stay Shady why don't we just
legitimize ourselves by appearing like a
legit company that's the funniest thing
I've ever heard do you like cuz it's not
like you don't have the manpower you
know like they don't have the money they
have the they just don't have the ethics
[ __ ] funny dude yeah there was this
documentary that explored all of this
that was still last year in 2016 it's
called dream Empire by David Bornstein
and David says quotes audiences are
watching you for your skin color not for
what you're doing it's kind of like
being a monkey
so that's like how he sees this whole
Rena foreigners phenomenon damn that's
crazy
so I just wanna like I understand the
mentality of I don't get it dude so it's
like you work so much harder to be a
cheater instead of just doing it right
because if everyone in China got
together and did things legit Dara
they're gonna be a unstoppable force
what David's also saying is that he was
also a rented foreigner he said that he
was once hired to play the role of a
drummer and he just had to pretend to be
a drummer over this the soundtrack
playing over so I guess they were like
filming something so it's like a Chinese
freakin bad but they're like you know we
need the white people to make it look
like a real punk band yeah so they just
hired the guy if foreigners are being
used to turn remote rule ghost towns
into globalized booming cities by having
these foreigners babyfaces I didn't
notice a trend because um before you
know like all Chinese companies either
have the word Jade or dragon or Emperor
and then in the name business flaming
okay flaming dragon so it'd be like
dragon toothbrushes or Jade tampons or
whatever right it's always that and now
when you look at these Chinese companies
the titles you know it's a Chinese
company when it's in English but the
titles don't make sense it's like
sunshine forever industries and you in
it's like a janitorial company yeah that
you're like what the [ __ ] is just
because they're just finding or happy
sounding American names like golden
mushroom
I don't know cars and there's no paper
golden mushroom automobile we specialize
in paper and napkins you know it just
blows my [ __ ] mind yeah but they're
saying that these random foreigner gigs
like these skyrocket whenever there's
like a political
visiting that certain area or things
like that to give it more legitimacy
don't they know that [ __ ] is fake they
just walk in like [ __ ] is there also
mentioning like the skilled consumer the
Chinese consumer they can tell like
which ones fake which ones real
obviously if there's a guy that's
pretending to [ __ ] work yeah okay the
leaders here just pretend like you're
gay understand the Chinese mindset cuz I
see my mom do it all the time it's if
the system doesn't fit what she wants
then she's gonna do it the Chinese way
so for example when she built her house
the one that we all lived that before in
her mind she is like I know I'm not
allowed to have a triplex here which is
like three residences but she's like but
I make so much more money if I have a
triplex
and the city won't let me have it so now
what she does is when she they even have
contractors already made for this so the
garage which was turned into kind of
like its own unit mm-hmm
when the inspectors came the Chinese
contractors already knew how to embed
gas and electrical lines underneath the
concrete so I'll pass the City Hall and
then when they leave they just have to
make little taps in the places that they
secretly mark and they continue with the
gas lines and all that stuff which are
not allowed in the garage so my mom does
the crazy Chinese way and there's an
entire market of this stuff because they
build houses just like this in Temple
City San Marino Rowland Heights Hacienda
like every single place even when we
bought when I got my car I went to a
predominantly Chinese place so it was
BMW and then legally in California if
they have your front and back license
plates but they were just like nah Matt
doesn't even look cool like we're not
even gonna put it on I'm like [ __ ] yeah
I love shady places they don't make it
to because they're not supposed to allow
you to drive off the lot way are you
putting that being on but then if it's
Chinese it's the person is more
important than what is the law yeah
that's why I got a front license plate
on my car huh the way that that Chinese
people see law is the concept more like
if it's not gonna hurt anybody who cares
you
yeah so it's like Oh murder we can do
murder that's that's gonna hurt somebody
yeah yeah yeah but if it's like whoosh
more like Chinese lies how they view
driving to like that red lies our
suggestion yeah you know I mean that can
kill someone though it can if you are
put in a place where everyone else is
following the rule that's why I like
driving in the 66 cuz it's [ __ ] up
it's scary but if you know how to plug
yourself into that system it's [ __ ]
awesome cuz I'm like dude I'm way the
wrong way nobody gives a [ __ ] it's not
even Chinese people it's like Kurt like
queer najin must to like right in front
of drips so I saw this lady like there's
cards coming by right like so there's a
restaurant across there's a bunch of
restaurants across she was coming out of
restaurant she was bought when you see
cars coming you stop this [ __ ] lady
had her cart full of like [ __ ] and she
just went slam its brakes you just
started going is like it's my turn I'm
gonna walk like especially when you go
shopping and like if there's like a shoe
sale going on they just go for it
they don't care I think it's the agen
people yeah mainly Koreans and Chinese
III don't yeah I can't really say
anything about Southeast Asians because
I don't think that the same as East
Asians I feel like they're more like
chill mm-hmm East Asians are pretty
[ __ ] intense to do - yeah so this
whole random foreigner thing they were
interviewing that article that I was
reading they were interviewing this one
guy and so he's saying that he moved to
China from Canada 20 years ago but that
he's really irritated by these people
taking these silly jobs because he says
quote they damage the reputation of us
foreigners in general and make it harder
for me to generate trust and credibility
when I'm meeting potential clients and
partners it's an industry built on a
platform of dishonesty and deceit that
sounds Chinese to me
loke oh that's he's kind of he's
experiencing what minorities experience
in America yeah we have sellout ass
Asians that are like [ __ ] man you're
making it [ __ ] harder for us now you
know you're making us look like a sack
of [ __ ]
[ __ ] but then now now this white guy
knows how it feels like when other wife
he will misrepresent him cuz I feel like
that's that's something that you know if
you're a majority of a country you don't
really experience that because you're
well represented yeah this whole
practice really reflects society's
general lack of confidence in their
cultural identity for sure 100% agree I
know that's the funniest thing how do
you change that whole country it's it's
hard cuz even when I go back to Taiwan
like when my uncle introduces me to his
friends or his friends kids it's always
this is Bart from America which means
it's that much better because I'm from a
Western place oh yes my family be like
oh she's English she's American like all
my cousins they was using it's like all
of a sudden your branding is that much
higher but there's also like like even
that to like the cost of the beauty I
think like in Jamaica right now well
there's there's like a whole skin
bleaching epidemic but these ladies are
don't do that they're making them look
lighter and then I watched like a couple
I thought it was just something that was
maybe like in a small but there's a lot
of people that are doing it and they're
interviewing these ladies like could I
look more beautiful like this lighter
skin is more beautiful I don't wanna be
dark and dirty all the [ __ ] Americans
white people out here are trying to get
darker yeah they want a tank because
they want to look like to go on a
vacation out of town yeah and then other
people are trying to be like pale so
they go like I am working I am now
working ever outdoors I am like
royalties I'm trying to be a monkey I
don't know what everyone else's values
are hey what's up guys thanks for
watching we are going to regularly start
posting content on the JK films
Instagram so make sure you follow us
there the last video click over here
[Music]